es ist ein seltener Blick in das
Herzstück des deutschen Stromnetzes hier
in der Schaltzentrale von Transnet BW
sorgen Sie rund um die Uhr dafür dass
das Netz nicht zusammenbricht wir dürfen
nicht alles zeigen auch nicht alle
Mitarbeiter die Furcht Terror Sabotage
oder Entführungen denn das Stromnetz
gehört zur kritischen Infrastruktur
deren Bedeutung durch die Ukraine Krieg
wieder verstärkt ins Bewusstsein gerückt
ist trotz aller sorgfältiger Planung
kann natürlich in Realzeit auch was
eintreten was man nicht geplant hat etwa
ein Blackout immer wieder gibt es die
Sorge vor einem großen Stromausfall wie
Mitte Januar die App des Netzbetreibers
springt auf rot waren vor einer
angespannten Lage und fordert dazu auf
Strom einzusparen was nun soweit drohten
gar unkontrollierte Ausfälle oder
zumindest Abschaltungen um das Netz zu
schützen nach 12 Minuten werden dann bei
uns tatsächlich Menschen ohne Strom
wir sind in der Schaltzentrale von
Transnet BW hier sorgen Jens
langenbecker und seine Mitarbeiter dafür
dass in Millionen von Haushalten das
Licht nicht ausgeht rund um die Uhr
überwachen Sie dafür die Stabilität des
überregionalen Stromnetzes bewegt sich
die Frequenz doch einmal in ein
kritischen Bereich müssen Sie eingreifen
im größten Notfall hieße das auch einen
brownout also eine kontrollierte
Abschaltung anzuweisen umgesetzt würde
diese aber nicht hier sondern
zehneinhalb km südöstlich und zwar in
der Zentrale von Netze BW dem
angeschlossenen Verteilnetzbetreiber
auch sie gehören zur kritischen
Infrastruktur auch hier dürfen wir nicht
alles zeigen sobald die Anweisung zum
Abschalten ankommen würde startet ein
festgelegter Plan
wir bekommen die E-Mail von der Transnet
BW dann haben wir sechs Minuten Zeit um
die Last aufzuteilen auf unser eigenes
Netz was unsere Anteil ist und für die
etwa 95 nachgelagerten Netzbetreiber die
dann wiederum von uns eine E-Mail
bekommen nach diesen sechs Minuten
müssen wir wissen wo die die Last ist
und zwar wurden wir dann anfangen zu
schalten nach 12 Minuten werden dann bei
uns tatsächlich Menschen ohne Strom und
bei den nachgelagerten die haben noch
mal sechs Minuten mehr Zeit abgeschaltet
würde diskriminierungsfrei übersetzt
heißt das im Fall der Fälle entscheidet
ein Algorithmus mit Zufallszahlen bei
wem das Licht ausgehen würde jeden
könnte es also treffen jedes Mal aufs
Neue
hier könnte man zum Beispiel so ein
bisschen abschätzen wie ich solche
abschaltgruppen aussehen könnten ja das
werden dann einige solcher Kreise
zusammengefasst die im Falle eines einer
rollierenden Abschaltung wäre dieses
Bild ja an vielen Stellen rot darüber
wenn man kleinen flächig dann versuchen
das zu verteilen über das Netz und dann
werden hier halt einzelne Gemeinden
stromlos das Ziel dieser kontrollierten
Abschaltungen das Netz zu sichern und
Schlimmeres zu verhindern also einen
Blackout einem langen unkontrollierten
und großräumigen Stromausfall doch wieso
sind eigentlich mehrere Betreiber im
Ernstfall involviert die Antwort liegt
im eng vernetzten Stromnetz in
Deutschland ist das ähnlich dem
Straßennetz in verschiedenen Ebenen
eingeteilt ganz oben stehen die vier
übertragenes Netzbetreiber Transnet BW
50 Herz am Brian und Tennet über ein
Höchstspannungsnetz leiten sie Strom
über weite Strecken etwa aus Offshore
Windparks im Norden bis hin zu
Ballungszentren im Süden Verteiler neben
den Strom dann entgegen und
transportieren ihn über ein hochmittel
und Niederspannungsnetz bis hin zu
heimischen Steckdose wichtig damit das
Netz stabil bleibt müssen Verbrauch und
Erzeugung stets im Einklang sein
andernfalls droht die Netzüberlastung
zurück zu Transnet damit es gar nicht
erst zu Abschaltung kommen muss beginnen
die Planung schon ein Jahr früher in
regelmäßigen Abständen erstellen und
prüfen Experten sogenannte
stromfahrpläne bis zuletzt bleibt aber
unklar ob das Wetter die Planung nicht
doch über den Haufen wirft oder Störung
auftreten
-1 sicher sagen wer dazu das heißt wir
betreiben so es kann jederzeit ein
Element ausfallen kann der Leitung
ausfallen kann Transformator ausfallen
wir bleiben aber nicht so sicher dass
sozusagen beliebig viele Sachen
gleichzeitig ausfallen können insofern
es gibt natürlich auch Szenarien wo es
dann tatsächlich eine Einschränkung
kommen würde die Auswirkung des Ukraine
Kriegs haben die Frage nach
Stromausfällen verschärft vor allem ein
möglicher gasmangel die Betreiber der
großen Transportnetze führten daher im
Sommer eine Risikoanalyse durch das
Ergebnis krisenhafte Situation sein sehr
unwahrscheinlich aber nicht vollständig
ausgeschlossen und auch jetzt Monate
später gibt es noch keine Entwarnung
auch wenn sich abzeichnet die
Gegenmaßnahmen zeigen
aber dann doch Aufregung die App von
Transnet springt auf Rot fordert Kunden
dazu auf den Verbrauch zu reduzieren
viele Nutzer hatten Angst vor einem
Stromausfall doch war das tatsächlich
berechtigt
als ich meine App damals geöffnet habe
habe ich das hier gesehen also ich sehe
da jetzt das sonntags ist ein rot
eingezeichnet nachmittags noch ein
bisschen gelb und dann ab 17 Uhr und da
steht er jetzt Verbrauch reduzieren
können Sie mal erklären was war denn da
los weil wenn man das so sieht kurz
macht man sich ja schon sorgen
jetzt an dem Tag war die Situation
werden sehr sehr viel Wind in
Deutschland der wird im Wesen in
Norddeutschland produziert also Strom
war eigentlich genügend da ähm aber der
Strom muss auch übertragen werden können
und wenn das nicht der Fall ist dann
greifen wir das System so ein dass wir
praktisch in Norddeutschland die erzogen
etwas reduzieren das was wir nicht
transportieren können und dafür in
Süddeutschland Erzeugung erhöhen die
dann sozusagen die Stromversorgung
übernimmt das was Jens lang Becker
erklärt den Fachleute wie er wie
dispatch Eingriffe die Engpässe
verhindern sollen und damit am Ende auch
Abschaltungen die Eingriffe müssen
jedoch immer öfter stattfinden die
Folgen die Produktion von grünem Strom
wird reduziert klimaschädlichere
Kraftwerke eingesetzt und Strom
importiert die Kosten dafür zahlen auch
die Kunden mit der Energiewende
verschärft sich die Situation denn es
fehlt schlichtweg an Kapazitäten etwa um
Windstrom aus dem Energie reichen Norden
in den Süden zu transportieren und der
Baum neuer Netze der lässt auf sich
warten
Beispiel die Trasse südling sie soll
Windstrom von der Nordsee in den Süden
Deutschlands transportieren eigentlich
hätte sie schon letztes Jahr im Betrieb
gehen sollen nun soll es erst 2028
soweit sein Südost Link soll erst 2027
Strom transportieren ob die Termine
jedoch zu halten sind fraglich auch weil
Bürger die stromautobahn verhindern
wollen sie sind gegen die Eingriffe und
Veränderungen ihrer Region
die Betreiber hingegen fordern von der
Politik mehr Tempo sprich schnellere
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren
hätten wir heute zum Beispiel oder
unsere Kollegen im Übertragungsnetz
schon die südlichen Kleidung am Netz und
und diese Dinge dann wäre diese
Gesamtsituation noch deutlich
entspannter als im Moment ist und und
wir müssen um die Energiewende
voranzutreiben um um und stabiles Netz
hinzustellen müssen wir einfach
Leitungsausbau betreiben um auch diese
Klimaziele zu erreichen also hat man
irgendwie auch so ein bisschen selber
was verschlafen
ich denke aus unserer Sicht nicht wir
sind wirklich seit vielen Jahren dran
aber wir haben jetzt hier im Norden von
Baden-Württemberg seit 10 bis 12 Jahren
eine Leitung genehmigt über 25 km oder
sind in der Genehmigung wir haben mit
dem Bau noch nicht angefangen die
angespannte Situation auf dem Strommarkt
ist in Deutschland also auch hausgemacht
und könnte durch jede weitere Krise auf
dem Energiemarkt verschärft werden das
heißt aber nicht dass ein Blackout kurz
bevorsteht dieser bleibe laut Experten
weiter sehr unwahrscheinlich auch
kontrollierte Abschaltung sei nicht
deutlich realistischer geworden gab es
das hier bei Netze BW überhaupt schon
einmal nein unsere Aufgabe ist
normalerweise die Kunden mit Strom zu
versorgen und sie nicht vom Netz zu
brennen unser Job hier ist es natürlich
aber auch auf alles vorbereitet zu sein
und deshalb haben wir noch mal alles
vertieft die Pläne sie sind also da und
die Mitarbeiter vorbereitet auch wenn
derzeit alles danach scheint dass der
Ernstfall bei den Netzbetreibern nicht
so schnell eintreten wird zumindest
vorerst